sleepless is a remake of the French film
sleepless night and this film stars
Jamie Foxx and Michelle Monaghan Fox
plays a cop who's attempting to rescue
his son from some drug dealers and he's
caught smack-dab in the middle of a very
complex situation he's trying to prove
himself to the cops and he's trying to
prove himself to these drug dealers
because all that really matters to him
is his son at this point and all this
takes place over the course of one night
at a Las Vegas casino I didn't really
have much anticipation for this movie in
fact the studio is essentially throwing
this film out as far as I know there
were no screenings for critics I looked
right before filming this and there's
not a single review as of filming this
posted on Rotten Tomatoes I didn't have
a screening yet I had screenings for
monster trucks and the bye-bye man can't
it's January what does that tell you
it tells you you shouldn't always judge
a book by its cover because I had a ton
of fun sleepless this is not a great
film this does have flaws and we're
going to get into those but I would
relate this film to a movie called safe
it came out of four years ago with Jason
Statham another action film that takes
place largely over the course of one
night and it's a perfectly fun enjoyable
escapist action movie that doesn't do
much beyond that it doesn't try to
overreach it doesn't try to have a
message this film just really wants to
be entertaining and I really enjoyed it
the photography of Las Vegas is
fantastic at night there's non-stop
action essentially I love movies that
take place over the course of one
contained period of time because they
always have a sense of urgency a lot of
the die hard films for instance when
your main characters in the film has no
time and they're in the middle of a
terrible situation and they have to
constantly dig themselves out of this
hole that they dug for themselves and
now they have to figure out how to get
out
it makes the film really interesting and
Jamie Foxx is actually really fantastic
in this movie he had a very complex
character one that I wasn't entirely
sure what side he was on for a large
portion of the movie despite the fact
that looking back on it there's definite
hints as to what is going on with his
character I really like the fact that he
wasn't just some throwaway Cop character
he had a lot to him he had a backstory
he had a life he had a reason for being
there beyond just the fact that his son
was there as well it was more than just
I need my son and you have him there was
a lot more on the tape
for his character michelle monaghan is
also really good as a badass cop who
people are doubting because she got beat
up and she made some really wrong
decisions when she was trying to do a
bust and she's now trying to prove
herself
so each main character has something
behind him or her that's really pushing
them to try and giving them all a sense
of urgency it's not just you took my son
and I'm going to kill you there's more
than just like a revenge style film now
there were some signs that I was
watching a January film for instance the
sound mixing in the earlier scenes now
there's always a chance that there's a
speaker broken or speaker out in the
theatre and it's throwing off the
equilibrium and I'm noticing it in this
case I don't think that's so because I
go to this theater all the time and it's
a pretty high quality sound system I
noticed that most early on in the scene
where Michelle Monaghan and Jamie Foxx
meet there's a helicopter noise in the
background that goes in and out and
their voices seemed really drowned out
as I said it's a chance it was my
theatre but there were some definite
sound mixing issues and some of the
early scenes of this film also
characters make some really stupid
choices in this movie to simply propel
the suspense of the film it's the kind
of film where the script wants
characters to do things that are stupid
just to make us feel like oh shit
something just happened and now we're
into it but these are cops who
admittedly are very desperate and I'm
not sitting here like an expert on
police procedure or anything but there
are certain sequences in this movie
where I was like really you went ahead
and did that I did a scene where Jamie
Foxx is in disguise he has a bald cap
really low and he's hiding in the
elevator and right before the doors
closed he looks up right at the person
he's hiding from and lets this person
know he's there
which causes a chase scene which leads
to a fight scene and I was like really
that's probably like why were you hiding
if you just wanted to let the person
know you were there like stupid choices
like that are made throughout this movie
that don't make sense that took me out
of the film there are definite shades of
Michael Mann here as well beyond the
fact that Jamie Foxx is in this movie
you can tell that a director is trying
to emulate that feel that off the cuffs
unhinged feel that Michael Mann is so
great with and there are sequences in
this movie that really impressed me but
it couldn't quite escape that feeling
that it wasn't very original but beyond
that I feel it's actually kind of
commendable that I am
examining the flaws of this movie as
deeply as I am because generally a
January movie that's just thrown into
theaters with no screenings you just
like forget this thing it sucks you know
but no I'm actually looking into
filmmaking here which shows you that
they were really trying Sleepless is a
much better film than I anticipated it
has very good performances it has some
very good action scenes although I wish
they were directed slightly better and
that there was a little more character
based reasons for these fight scenes and
for these elongated chase scenes beyond
the fact that hey let's have a chase
scene or a fight scene sometimes it does
feel like we just need to have an action
scene now it doesn't necessarily always
work scoot mcnairy shows up as a really
badass villain sometimes his performance
was off and on for me he does a lot of
weird stuff and make some really poor
choices as I said stupid character
choices for the purpose of suspense like
he hangs somebody upside down in the
middle of a baseball field a giant
public baseball field where anyone can
really walk in and fords the end of the
movie he's launching gas grenades around
in public and I'm like I thought you
didn't want to go to jail dude those
were some really bad choices
so beyond some of those stupid character
choices that are made in this film at
the head of the script I thought
sleepless was a lot more fun than I
anticipated Jamie Foxx as I said and
Michelle Monaghan are both very good in
this movie and I'm going to give
Sleepless of B this is 95 minutes of a
well shot disposable action thriller
with a couple really good performances
and if you can enjoy that in the middle
of January where we're watching movies
like monster trucks and the bye bye man
have a good time go see it guys thank
you so much as always for watching as
you can tell my background is kind of
x-men Fi except for the collateral
blu-ray of course that's because in
February I'm going to be doing an x-men
series of all the x-men films I haven't
reviewed that's x-men one two three and
a little film called origins my buddy
the flip pick was just here and we
filmed their origins review together
look forward to that in February guys
you are the best thank you so much as
always for watching I want to let you
know that my promotion with Squarespace
is still going on Squarespace is a great
web developing service that allows you
to have so many customizable simple fun
beautifully rendered options
to create your own website they have
24/7 customer support
I personally am extremely impressed with
what Squarespace has to offer on its
website I began doing movie reviews
largely because I started my own website
when I was a teenager
so when Squarespace got in contact with
me I was like this just fits
squarespace.com check them out you can
start your free trial today with this
extremely useful tool for web
development at squarespace.com slash
chris stuckman and use the coupon code
stuckman
and you can get 10% off guys you are the
best again thank you very much for
watching and if you like this you can
click right here and get stuck menage
[Applause]
[Music]